[Music]
[Applause]
uh Jane Slater NFL Network reporter
works for NFL game day morning and
you'll see that Saturday at noon Eastern
Sunday at 11:00 a.m. eastern and then
they spent hours and hours and hours up
until game time and she was at the Mike
McCarthy press conference yesterday and
Jane joins us on the
program help me understand Mike
McCarthy's demeanor yesterday if it was
defiant or confident or is there another
word that you would use to describe
him I think he used the words uh that I
would describe I think he said that he
was raw and a little numb to it all
talking about the playoff loss and how
it went and I you know we talked about
how hard and challenging you know
questions about his job security have
been for his family and so I I still
think even after four years there has
been an adjustment for Mike from what he
was used to in Green Bay and what comes
with you know players that have been
around here longer than him know it the
star on the helmet um and so I I think
it was almost like he was still
processing everything in real time up on
the podium and I know a lot has been
made of the question that I had to Mike
and it was you know I phrased it a lot
more sensitive than how it was been put
out there but you know I said to him I
said respectfully coach you've told us
why we should buy back in this team but
why should fans buy back into you and
you know he talked about the direction
the leadership everything's in place and
he's not very comfortable talking about
himself but he came to Dallas to win a
world championship not to get a contract
after his year you know away from Green
Bay but to win that world championship
and then he just ended it with Buy in
and I think a lot of fans took issue
with that they almost I think wanted to
hear something like we might hear from
Dan Campbell these days you know they
want to see the emotional like I think
about you guys every day and you know
let's go bite the kneecaps or you know
burn a bird uh for the NFC East it's
just we didn't get that and
so having covered Mike the last couple
of years I didn't expect a raw raw
speech but I also want to give him a
little Grace here that I do think that
this stuff and this job can sometimes
weigh on folks do you think Jerry Jones
reached out to other possible
candidates no and I've made a lot of
calls about that I've talked to people
internally I've talked to people on the
outside I even reached out to Bill bich
agent who doesn't like to get back to
most uh folks meil uh but everyone I've
talked to seems to suggest that a call
was never even made to Bill not
dissimilar from last year when we heard
so much about Shawn Payton as you'll
remember Dan Shawn never got a call from
Jerry and so some of this is this is
Jerry Jones a lot of it you know I
didn't think it was productive leading
up to the playoff game for Mike who
already I was told last year when he
went to Lambo and you know face the
Packers for the first time that he was
tight that he was tense about it and it
was almost like he confirmed that this
week when he got ahead of it and said I
know the narrators are there it didn't
help us last year talk about the Packers
you know they were focused on the game
but you know when you've just won a big
one I'll be it it was against the
commanders but I would remind everyone
remember laid an egg on the road against
the commanders last year when it was Sam
hell's first start they had a big win
and in the locker you know Outside The
Locker Room Post
game Jerry sort of sewing um there
wasn't a lot of confidence in the sense
that it was you know you could have said
you know Mike's my guy look at the 12
wins we're so excited to get into the
postseason there wasn't really that and
then it took him going on the radio want
to fight through the fanda store baby
put it to bed as the it was like put it
to bed light and then you still had you
know people who I really respect in this
business Adam schfer and Peter King
putting out this narrative that hey
Bill's out there and if this thing goes
south you know they're gonna make a
phone call um I don't I don't think that
that helped Mike and so I you know they
talked about it and Jerry talked about
it postgame about you know needing to
take accountability and I I I hope that
Jerry also sees there's a level of
accountability that sometimes he needs
to take as you know you want people to
do good I don't think it feels really
great when your boss isn't coming out
and saying um throwing all their
supports as as much as they can behind
you and if you talk to Stephen and Jerry
about it I mean they're not wrong
everyone's job is always up for
evaluation I mean I think you and I are
also in that evaluation business and so
I I understand it I just don't think it
helps it if I said to the fan base you
can change ownership change the coach
change the quarterback how do you think
that vote would
go uh if you're listening to Dallas
radio or I always consider my father as
a great pulse check here in Dallas I
grew up here he is the typical Dallas
Cowboys fan that takes the flag off of
the house when they lose and tells you
he's done with the team and he's going
to return his jersey and of course he
never does you know so I kind of laugh
about it but yeah I mean I think the
fans get frustrated with Jerry uh
because I think that you know the the
push back every year is she can't fire
the GM because Jerry is the GM uh but I
do think that people don't understand
that Jerry does he doesn't make a lot of
these decisions in a vacuum I mean he
does really weigh what will mlay and
player personel have to say and and for
that matter you know people want to know
why is Mike McCarthy coming back I was
really you know I reached out to a lot
of players you know they had an
opportunity for off the Record
discussions about Mike McCarthy I I just
wanted to heat check you know what was
the temperature of the locker ra and Dan
they were so supportive of Mike they
wanted him back and I think a lot of
people just assumed that this team quit
on Mike they did it and a lot of them
took ownership for the way that that
they played but I think that the problem
for you know at least the Cowboys fans
right now is yeah 12 wins are great and
you're getting into the postseason but
these early exits and more importantly
the way they're losing and the way they
don't seem to show up I mean the first
one here with you know Jimmy G it was in
your own building and then you don't get
the ball
uh to the ref in time at the end of the
game game over embarrassing uh last year
you go up to Santa Clara and once you
lose Tony Pard all of a sudden this team
is onedimensional and then your final
memory of Ezekiel Elliott is him lining
up at Center and then this year I mean
the fact that here you were driving the
ball you thought you had a chance right
before the half uh and it's
27-0 after darell Savage gets the pick
six and then they finally put up points
in the fourth quarter after Alexander
comes out of the game I mean I just it
doesn't Inspire confidence about what
this team is capable of and I think more
importantly one stat that really stands
out to me was they're now two and six at
least from this season including the
post when the opposing team scores on
the first drive and so it's like they
can't if they don't get on the board
early and they don't score early they
have a hard time bouncing back and even
this defense as much as you know I think
all of us like Dan Quinn and I mean if
you talked to anybody Locker him man
they they'll run through a wall for him
this year they were getting hammered
against teams that were good and so I
just I think everything has to be
evaluated and listening to Mike McCarthy
at a three-hour conversation with Jerry
when they went over the course of all of
this and now you know we're being told
Dak Prescott's you know coming back I
mean you really can't move on from him
uh with his 59 almost 60 million C hit
and Mike says he is part of the solution
well what about your 16 other free
agents you know what does this mean for
Micah Parsons what does this mean for CI
lamb as stevenh Jones will tell you year
after year there's only so many pieces
of the pie so I think that that's where
this is going to get really really
interesting yeah I brought this up
during the season I said you know no
matter how this season ends you know
Dallas could be in a bad situation
because they have really good players CD
lamb is going to want a big contract
Micah Parson's going to want a big
contract and dak's going to have a big
number there as well so I don't know how
they get around are they going pay all
three and then what's the Fallout from
that with the rest of the
roster well they always I'll say this
about the Cowboys they always figure out
a way and a lot of that is unfortunately
why we're here with that Prescott is
they will push the money towards the
back end but then you're stuck with I
mean we saw this with Tony Rumble I mean
they had to eat Tony rumo's money too
luckily they had a four string
quarterback in that Prescott who just
had an incredible rookie season you felt
good moving on even though you had to
eat that but you're kind of a little bit
in cap hell there for a second and so I
think the question is like how do they
play with this money and do they give
you the money up front and then they
push the money uh down the line I think
those are all those are all questions
they've got right now the big thing that
I don't think a lot of people realize
that holding him up with Dak Prescott is
he also uh Todd France Tipp of the cap
to him very shrewd agent for Dak got him
a no trade clause in there and a no
franchise tag uh
so you know this that it's going to be
really interesting to see what they do
with that Fel great to talk to you I
know you got a busy morning thanks for
making time for us Jane of course always
a pleasure and I'll always make time for
you in the D ads all right thank you
that's Jane Slater NFL Network reporter
making time for you guys